our second thought today is also
focusing on traffic mobility here we're
looking as Jan said of Alex's talk about
routing games thank you very much Peter
thank you very much for the invitation
I'm very excited to be here and hi to
our millions of viewers millions of
people watching live today I'm gonna
talk about inference I'm controlling
routing games in the specific context of
transportation though routing game is
obviously much broader topic that
applies to many networks Internet in
particular first thing I'd like to do is
to talk generally about transportation
as a system which is the framework that
is used for the what we do here and so
if any of you has taken any introduction
to controls class that Caltech and many
other books many other places including
Berkeley use that that's the way you
learn to think about a control system
with their actuation system sensors and
then a controller to go with it then so
the way I'd like to walk through the
transportation system today is in the
same fashion to give you a sense of
what's been done on the modeling and
control side in each of the different
boxes and the work done in inference in
some of them so the core obviously is
the system dynamics which is pretty
complex to model whether you're looking
at something as crazy as this which
happens every nearly every day in LA or
Thanksgiving traffic the point here is
there's been probably half a century of
modeling work done transportation
systems anything from coupled PD systems
to queueing systems to even simpler
models that somehow work we do and
everybody does relies on and we've
contribute assess ourselves over time
then they're sensing infrastructure
which in the case of transportation
traditionally has not been very
widespread mostly for cost reasons and
these are things you've seen on the road
many times when you drove through
different places California or elsewhere
Luke sensors cameras radars and many
other things then you control
infrastructure which also you're
familiar with if you drive in most
states of the u.s. obviously traffic
lights in cities but also for freeways
things like metering lights like this
things like metering for bridges things
like special use lanes which is a way to
control traffic you can enter the lane
or cannot enter Lorraine or you can
enter for some prizes or things a bit
more sophisticated such as variable
speed limits or speed advisories and so
if you think about for example a fairly
well instrumented corridor like the i2
10 in la that infrastructure is still a
fairly small size you have a total asset
inventory of about 450 live traffic
lights and meters maybe 50 other types
of wayfinding signs that can help and
that's essentially so maybe total of 500
is all you have to manage hundreds of
thousands of people living there going
through that corridor every day so
that's you don't need to be an expert in
control theory to figure out that this
is a very small amount of actuation when
it comes to controlling the system now
on the control side there's two
important blocks which are estimation or
nowcast inference and then demand
forecast which is essentially trying to
predict what's going to come into the
system which you can conceptualize as
follows so typically if this is a
screenshot of the system we're building
for LA if you're trying to do inference
you're essentially calling a 2d plot
where the color level indicates now so
this is time and this is place
essentially the speed on the freeway and
that's that's the most simple graphical
way of characterizing what inference is
so you're as the time Falls until now
you use you estimate what what traffic
is and then forecast is more done for
demand which is because it's much harder
to forecast the state but you can at
least folk at the forecast demand
statistically that's essentially saying
well there's gonna be a peak demand and
the morning rush there's gonna be
another peak demand in the
evening rush and something in the middle
and there are fairly good statistical
models of these things and so what you
do on it essentially and that's the job
of any Traffic Management Agency is
based on estimation and forecast to try
to optimize over the corridor which you
could conceptually think well if you if
your goal is to have a free flow means
everybody going the speed limit
you'd essentially want to paint this in
green it's not true in general because
things never stay green I mean if the
freeways were just come just at all the
time more people would start to drive
that's called induced demand but but
just conceptually think about
optimization that's trying to do your
preferred column pattern here which is
what you try to achieve the location is
location is this would be post miles so
say you start from a location on the
freeway you declared zero and then the
flow is 15 miles long that would be 15
miles it's a network so this is a link
by link representation and every link
you click and so the two we're building
every link you click and you can see
this so then it says I think this has
been referred to as a time-space diagram
for 50 years by traffic engineers I mean
is that probably many other names in
different different fields that if you
really cleaned up the roads and this is
what we're going to go to it over the
second part of the talk is induced
demand works on different time scales
because people you don't want it feels
like the objective you want to optimize
to might be non-trivial because
if you optimize to a trivial objective
you might just exactly exactly and and
so this is a nice teaser for about 30
minutes from now but ask me again in 30
minutes because then we'll go into
conspiracy theory so ask me again about
the conspiracy theory in about 30
minutes so this essentially feeds an
operator because in most of the systems
even though these are not safety
critical as you would have in a VA ssin
you still have an operator and so this
is a picture of the le a District seven
command center that we're building this
decision support system for and Ally
Metro which is the MPO the Metropolitan
and public organization agency in charge
of this of this jurisdiction there's
always two agencies the state and the
MPO and so the point in building this is
that you like I drew you were hinting
you can't optimize for anything and in
fact you have to be really careful what
you optimize for mostly because there's
a lot of jurisdictions in charge of the
geography so they they inevitably will
always have conflicting interests I mean
you can see if there are many cities
along the corridor not all of them have
the same objective in terms of where
they want cars to go if you have a state
in charge of the freeway but an MPO in
charge of their channels how you balance
traffic between the two is not obvious
so for those of you who have done
optimization in a sense here the
feasible set is the set of acceptable
procedures that all the stakeholders
agree to and so to define what you
optimize over essentially what you do is
you write a concept of operation which
is a set of pre agreed rules that all
the stakeholders said okay to do and so
that's in a sense how you define your
feasible set for your optimization
program and in the present case for LA
for the I 210 we wrote it on behalf of
the stakeholder involved in the corridor
so let's talk a little bit about
inference problems so inference problems
mostly have to do with either forecast
of demand or demand or state estimation
so in the case of demand forecast one of
the things and these
probably so some of it in the end Jane's
talk earlier is with the explosion of
the use of cell phones there are big
Buddhist even if you don't query every
phone's GPS track which gives you
position within a few meters by just
squaring the cell tower it's talking to
which any operator does you have an
approximate positioning which can be on
the order of 500 meters wrong it's okay
not good enough to do traffic flow
estimation or speed estimation but good
enough to do demand estimation and the
band estimation is saying well from your
neighborhood where you live say within
the block or ten blocks to your work
location say the middle of the financial
district there's X thousand people
leaving at 8:00 in the morning and
arriving at 9:00 in the morning and so
the type of the work that are emanated
from the community over the last 10
years and some of it is essentially
creating algorithms that can do this
type of inference and it turns out that
you you can do this quite efficiently
with simple quadratic programs that
essentially model an approximate routing
of the people along their way because if
you look at the records you have you can
you can essentially track the person
from South Tower to cell tower so as you
drive in your car in the morning your
phone switches are from South Tower to
cell tower which gives you an
approximate which gives telecom company
that owns your cell phone plan an
approximate sense of your routing and
then with simple quadratic programs that
can be accelerated with isotonic
regression of what we can show is that
we can get really good inference of
demand patterns and that's that's
something which from a theoretical
standpoint is not that hard but I think
from a practical standpoint is essential
because if you think about five years
ago or 10 years ago the only way to get
to people's routing was essentially by
sensors people would knock on your door
ask where you work give you a bunch of
questions that would be updated every 10
years and that's how they would be doing
demand forecasts so over the last ten
years with this explosion of this data
essentially the lot of companies have
enabled the collection of data that can
really change the way this inference is
done and to give you a sense of what the
data looks like this is set of
our record so just focus on the purple
here the purple is the blue or bunch of
vehicles and the purple is one specific
vehicle that happens to be traveling
through LA and the points along the
trajectory or not the vehicles position
there the position of the cell tower
it's talking to which is white which is
a little jerk here that's because it's
being handed off to a tower there's none
of the that is off the freeway but the
point here is you can see from that
trajectory you can get an approximate
person's trajectory and if you bundle
this to company like AT&T probably has
40% of the population in California that
means you can get approximate origin and
destination from people for 40% which
then you can scale to the entire
population and you can see interesting
things this is probably a FedEx truck
that is doing deliveries so it's kind of
going around a part of the city
delivering packages this is someone
going to work stopping along the way
probably to do some shopping and then
going home and this is another person
traveling and so the type of work you do
with this is you take this data for the
proportion of the population you have
which is high and essentially you solve
the quadratic programs I've shown before
which is saying trying to minimize an
error functional between your
measurements and what your model
predicts subject to a constraint which
could be a model and in our case it's a
game theoretic model and that gives you
for each origin destination flow split
so say the model will say that from the
three thousands vehicle and air that
leave this origin and go to this
destination fifty percent use this route
forty percent use that route and say ten
percent are kind of spread in the less
red routes here that's what the model
that's there'd be a graphical way of
explaining what the model gives you and
so the interesting types of things you
can do with this are as follows for
example questions that you would want to
ask and you can at least answering
simulation is what should be the cell
tower density so that you can have a
specific set of errors so you obviously
like to have an error which is as small
as possible and that problem is going to
explode naturally because you can
imagine a number of roads between any
origin and destination is exponential in
the number of links so you have to make
choices
Google will typically give you three
routes usually from your origin to your
destination so depending on whether you
constrain your program by a number of
routes which is 3 to 50 you can see the
error is running better if you give 50
possible routes obviously your search
pace is bigger so when you optimize then
you probably get closer to reality and
so that is something that he can factor
in and so if you plot the relative error
between your ground truth and your
prediction what you can see is obviously
a decrease the more sales you have the
more precise you can track people but
also the more you allow them to take
routes then the bigger the program gets
but it's so it's more expensive
computationally than the lower of the
error so these are interesting
trade-offs to explore if you're trying
to predict routes of people at an
approximate level which is essentially
what you use to feed a more precise
model for local traffic so this is not
good for traffic control this is really
good for forecast of demand and that's
really important because the second part
so that's this box here is very
important because obviously another part
of controlling traffic is understanding
what's happening now at post mile 12.7
because there is an accident and that's
a very different problem that's a local
problem and that's also something which
we've worked on and I'll talk a little
bit about in the next couple of minutes
so here the problem is now local so we
go back to this time-space diagram this
is time and this is a post pile going
back to your question and so typically
if you want to control traffic any
controller will need some state input so
inference of the state and that's in a
sense the state so here's an example of
a accident that happens that creates a
big traffic jam that creates a back
propagation of a shock wave and then the
freeway never really recovers and it
says the evening peak of course you
never measure that because you would
have to measure every vehicle everywhere
so say you start with nothing so just
shaded it and say that this is what you
want to reconstruct if you were able to
sample the data at fixed location like
what sensors by counting cars which is
commonly done in California that's
essentially saying you can measure the
data on this on these axes sometimes
there's a
your sensor goes down so you don't have
data then it kicks in again and you
measure the data if you have a good
sense of what data is at midnight
because usually it's pretty empty except
maybe in LA
some places then technically you could
also initialize the inference here and
then if you were able to sample some
vehicles because now you have access to
their precise GPS location then that
means you can sample the data along some
trajectories and sometimes you don't
transmit your position all the time so
say you have a fast track reader or easy
pass and you in the East Coast you just
check-in at specific places like at the
tolls and other readers along the way so
you can so this vehicle here at this
time is the same as this vehicle here so
that's a good graphical summary of the
type of data that you get when you do
traffic estimation and for those of you
and I know there's a folks from a few
folks from Elvia now who work in
oceanography I mean essentially this is
Lagrangian sampling because you're
sampling or along the particle and this
is all orient sampling because
essentially it's sampling in a control
volume and these are terminology that
progressively are migrating to
transportation but they are mostly from
other physical oceanography and physical
sciences and so in doing data
assimilation or inverse modeling
typically you have a constitutive
equation so if your hydrodynamics is
usually you'll use navier-stokes
equation or if you're doing estuarine
environments you'll do shallow water
equations or if you're doing atmospheric
boundary layer you'll do different
versions of navier-stokes equation here
the PDE that you routinely use in
traffic is the hamilton-jacobi equation
where the Hamiltonian is a specific
function that encodes the level of
congestion of the road and that's a
function that was postulated in 1935 by
someone in brusque windshield and that
has been since then called the final
diagram in classical Hamiltonian
mechanics is called Hamiltonian
conservation laws it's called the flux
function it has a lot of different names
depending on the mathematical subdomain
so the point here is that you're doing
inference or you're doing data
assimilation which is essentially again
trying to reduce a functional error
subject to constraint and the constraint
is this hamilton-jacobi equation which
is nonlinear which is
which has non smooth solution and which
is essentially the the model of a plant
that you're trying to do to have here
and so if you're measuring that function
at a given location with a Alerian
measurement that's essentially saying
you can sample the function at a given
location at all the times if you are
postulating that the function is for
example empty freeway at midnight that's
saying you can tell that's the value of
the function on that line and then the
interesting thing about the Lagrangian
measurement is that it's always the same
car you're following so if people don't
pass each other too much because M
happens to represent the number of the
car on the freeway if you just number
people by the time they pass a reference
point essentially it's saying that
function is constant along the
Lagrangian trajectory and there was
something which was kind of known since
the 60s the guy who invented this is an
engineer from Caltrans called called
Moskowitz that's why we call the
function EMA in kind of remembering
Moskowitz because he had no idea about
PDC I don't think he was even training
and the vertical analysis but somehow
figured out that there was a function as
what there was conserved and discovered
the hamilton-jacobi equation without
realizing it was Mountain Jacobi
equation so it's kind of a very
interesting story from a practitioner
standpoint and it turns out that you can
example that function along a car and so
if you follow that trajectory it's
saying that most Co its function is
constant
it turns out that function satisfies the
hamilton-jacobi equation which is
another historical interesting thing
because the existence and uniqueness of
the solution to that equation only goes
to its era it's essentially 1982 and
that's a very famous paper of kondal
evans here at Berkeley and the
oscillator at Fields Medal and that's
the viscosity solution so it's something
that is still kind of recent in
mathematical time scales so here
the inference game is essentially trying
to reduce an error functional subjected
to this constitutive model and whatever
data you can measure and so part of the
contributions we've made over the years
is pose these problems
come up with existence and uniqueness
proofs of the solution because the
Lagrangian Dida creates extra
complications that are not in their
classical viscosity solution and then
leveraging an interesting formula called
the lilac soap formula it turns out you
can solve this equation semi explicitly
in a one-dimensional case and you can
integrate boundary conditions and
initial conditions and internal
conditions so these conditions into the
problem formulation which is interesting
too because it's not something you would
have a typical Cauchy problem and the
resulting thing you can get from putting
all these things together is you can
pose the data simulation problem as a
convex program where the problem is
convex in the parameter data that you
don't have which could be either the
noise you model in the data or the
uncertainty in the model and so this
took several papers
to put together but it's really nice
because it gives a generic framework for
data assimilation which systematically
leads to convex optimization program as
long as you model your error functional
as a quadratic error of some of the
parameters and so heavily relied on the
first book we wrote about ten years ago
now on viability theory and then we're
writing a second part specific to the
solutions here because it turns out this
framework has also had a lot of
different applications in control as
well so to give you a sense of how it
works if you were able to sample every
if you were able to sample 2% of the
people on the freeway every three
seconds so imagine you know every every
50 cars someone sends you data every
three seconds
this is what you would see so this is a
GPS track sample on that small stretch
of freeway and the color indicates the
level of congestion which is the speed
here essentially you can see that with
two percent of traffic you can you can
pretty much see what's happening
obviously companies like Google have
something much closer to hundred percent
because of either the Android phones
which have it in the US or the people
who have iPhones who use Google Apps
also send their location but what's
important to realize is that none of the
public agencies into
of traffic have access to that data
because that data is not shared and so
if you buy data at a very very small
percentage of the population German some
companies sell that that's more likely
what you'll get so here I've just
decimated the previous data set to only
keep a few and it's obvious from this
plot that it's much harder to
reconstruct traffic the error in your
reconstruction as a function of how much
in the analysis of the error as a
function of how much data we collected
so it would be statistical guarantee on
something based on what my algorithm
produces and what my true solution is as
a function of how much data I collect so
we've never quantified this as a
function of how much data we collect
because we don't know how to solve that
problem
but the one thing we have done well
because I mean like explicitly and
obviously we do it empirically and we
can show convergence plots empirically
but we don't have any explicit bounds
but okay but the one thing we can do is
we can actually characterize as a convex
feasibility problem the following
problem is like if we can if we assume
the error level so say for example
robust so take the maximum possible
error in the measurement is that much
and if we assume the model parameters of
yeah well I know it's more yeah I know
it's not exactly what you guys think
it's like robust vs. or and so that is
something we can pose as a convex
program now giving you an explicit ban
of convergence I think that's the
questions many people have asked and I
don't know how to do it not yet maybe in
ten years but we do but we but I don't
have them in this talk but we do have a
bunch of nice plots that show
convergence obviously of the estimator
as you increase the data they're just
empirical and so I think the interesting
perspective on this is that that
question might actually become moot in
in a few years because this is a there's
an interesting curve which shows the the
convergence or the increase in cell
phone ownership in the u.s. population
but if you think about the world of
transportation in five years where
people have multiple cell phones and
your car itself is connected in a sense
inference might become useless because
at least some agents like Google like
Apple like maybe even uber when they
will have enough data to just collect
data for enough people that you don't
even need a model anymore and I think
this is a really interesting transition
because people have spent the last
century in modeling traffic and it turns
out that you probably will spend the
next century just watching traffic and
pulling the data so if you go to like
you know the full IOT car where
telematics is just built built-in and it
propagates into the fleet are there any
qualitative advantages to that rather
than providing on the passenger this the
cargo - so like is the and for people
online the question is is there an
advantage of people providing data
through their personal cell phone versus
the car itself of the vehicle itself
through IOT paradigms sending it instead
it really depends what you're doing if
you're doing traffic management the
ladder is better because what you're
interested in is the vehicle the rest is
irrelevant but if you're doing demand
management because now you're trying to
push people from transit to car or car
to transit or you're trying to infer
what people are doing as people then the
other one is better because what you
care about is the people in particular
if you're interested in ridership you
would like to know how many cell phones
are in a vehicle because that's an
indicator of how many people are in a
car so
probably that would probably be
telematic okay so then okay okay so um
let me just skip a few things so that we
stay on track so let me summarize in a
sense one of the one of the things that
that we did was to build one of these
first systems and this is now ten years
ago we had our 10 year anniversary this
month and essentially what we did in
2008 was to we look this is what the
website with traffic information would
look like then and we built one of the
first systems that could essentially
create something like what you got on
your phones through ways or Google or
any other app from probe data it was
launched here from Berkeley and so these
are these are to give you a sense of
what that data looks like this is a plot
of 500 vehicles sampled at 30 seconds
interval in San Francisco this happened
to come from the cab spotting feed we're
getting at the time this is the data
that Jane probably described in the
previous talk so this is what you
measure if you have about 0 / 5 percent
of the people sending their data every
minute and what's interesting is that
even with 500 vehicles at this very very
low frequency you get a lot of
information to give you a sense of the
magnitude
guber has I think 40,000 registered
drivers in San Francisco and each of
them is collecting that data at the 1
second frequency I assume and that's
just by watching the car moving on the
map you can see it's roughly updating
its position every one second so there
must be at least collecting that
position every one second and so that's
interesting because you can see that
we're progressively entering an era in
which these estimation problems like you
are asking might become moot if there is
enough data that you can just look and
almost literally do it vehicle by
vehicle but we shouldn't forget that
there are lots of places in the world
including the u.s. word that data is
still not ubiquitous and
and and so I think a lot of these
companies that have built systems like
the one I described have essentially
built an architecture just like the one
we used at Berkeley for the last ten
years which is like you gather all your
feeds and these are all the data sources
I showed before there's a bunch of
filters the models I spoke a little bit
about Jacobi equation then the
predictors which we solve as convex
programs and that essentially provide
traffic information and so looking from
a historical perspective and technology
perspective we started working with this
problem about ten years ago at the time
with Nokia which was the giant telco
cell phone provider since then obviously
a lot of other agents have captured that
market today Google and Apple being the
two major collection of this data and I
think it's fair to say that you know
that not our problem not only has become
very mature from an academic standpoint
I mean there's been tons I've worked on
both in modeling estimation experiments
and even data quality but it's also
becoming mature from an industry
standpoint because I think this is in a
sense there's not much more money to be
made in this field most of the companies
will provide traffic information and
sell it are struggling and those will
give it for free are just doing it
because they can bundle their products
with it but what's interesting is the
consequences that this liquidus
technology has had on society because if
you think about I don't know how many of
you drove to Berkeley this morning or if
you're driving back to this other school
on the south of the bay in the afternoon
but the point is whenever you query
Sony's travel time usually what the app
does is it will give you one route and
it might give you two other routes that
are nearly as good and try it now try
plater
everybody has done that before what's
interesting is that if you look at this
diagram what it actually does is it
changes the dynamics inside the plan by
adding a feedback loop that is unique to
you because you're gonna follow an app
you're not going to follow directions
from the government or directions from
previous experience or do what the
government thinks
you're doing you're going to do what the
app tells you to do so essentially now
you're closing the loop inside the plant
and every is closing a different clip
because every is using a different app
for different purposes and if you put on
any control theory you know that having
a model of your system
in your controller that is different
that in the plant is a really bad idea
that's just like putting the cookie like
a jet fighter autopilot into a 747 is
not going to create a happy landing and
and so first thing about this is like
well maybe this is an academic problem
maybe it's it's actually not that bad
but it is actually really bad and let me
show you why these are interesting
snapshots I'll go through really fast or
you know statements made by politicians
or elected officials about the fact that
oh we're going to team up with this app
or that app and because people are
getting their shortest path traffic is
going to improve of course if you know
game theory you're already laughing I
can see people laughing because pretty
quickly what happened is not exactly
that but people noticing that some
problems happen in their neighborhood
due to through traffic and there are
several things that stake here but one
thing at stake is obviously what happens
when you query the app and you take a
shortest path is you're playing a
selfish game in which you're doing
selfishly what's best for you there's
nothing wrong with it because I mean who
likes to be stuck in traffic but what's
interesting is that what ended up being
an on problem initially is a problem if
you have a very large proportion of the
population using this because that means
now everybody is playing this selfish
game and the information that used to
not be there now enables you to play
that game so at some point it got really
bad to the point that people started to
react so first it was kind of funny
people shaming people saying you should
not come to my neighborhood and posting
signs then it got a bit more creative
people putting fake detour signs to
confuse people so that they would not go
through their neighborhoods there's a
few neighborhoods who started to pay
senior citizens to walk whether phone
open along the road to send fake
measurements to the app to spoof the
algorithm
there's actually manuals to do this you
can find them online how do you flee
algorithms and then cities started to
get involved in figure out well it's
like the resistance right it's better
when it's organized so cities started to
figure out this happened in Fremont not
so long ago but this happens everywhere
that if you start to uncoordinated
traffic lights or put a lot of
restrictions in your traffic you're
gonna make it impossible for people to
go through your neighborhoods there's
many ways you can do that so one way is
to put Street bombs which slows down
traffic so in huge increase of street
bums in a lot of cities or stop signs
very good for that as well turn
restrictions no more societal left turns
that's the proper way to call them in
traffic engineering and so the point
here is that what you see now is a lot
of cities making their own traffic worse
so that the algorithm stops sending more
people through their neighborhoods so
it's crazy right this is the - I mean
who can think about making their own
life miserable so people don't come to
their neighborhoods but that's
essentially what's happening to the
point that now the things have gotten
political this has reached the desk of
many elected officials this was one of
the forecast that finally happened
because ironically the first lawsuit
happened against so City suing a company
for sending more traffic that way and
that's kind of where we were today and I
think it's not unlikely that maybe in
the next one or two years we'll see a
class-action probably in the u.s. some
of these apps actually send people down
routes it doesn't know the answer to
just so can gather data to figure out
whether the show ruts are the only using
data that they've acquired because
people oh now we're into conspiracy this
is a this is a part of conspiracy I did
not talk about I do no plans to talk
about this actually happened this is a
really good question this happened this
used to be a common practice of the
company ways when they build their maps
for historical reason that's remember
I'll take a five-minute digression and
cut five minutes of the talk but at
least I can answer that so ten years ago
when way does it they may know the story
of ways the reason the reason why Waze
exists is in some parts of the world's
map change every day where is being an
Israeli company obviously in Israel the
maps change every day based on what's
happening so people wanted to find a way
to find what's the
today so the only way to do it is to
send people to measure whether the road
is blocked or not or whether there's
something on the road and the way ways
did it at the time is if for those of
you who are running the app about 10
years ago is there were goodies just
just like a Pokemon go and if you drive
through the goodie you make points in
this game and then you get better
virtual status in that virtual ranking
and that's the way they used to do it
now this was explicit people were now
you could wonder why would people waste
time and energy and feel to do it again
virtual ok that's a different story
actually and someone on record from that
company saying that during a few years I
think the the the mileage of the users
and the gamers was increasing by 25% so
people were driving 25% more to gain
virtual status polluting the environment
increasing congestion just to get to
drive-through goodies anyway that era is
is behind us I don't know honestly today
if a company like the ones we're talking
about would dare to send someone just to
measure traffic because I think if this
was found out I think this would be
really bad so I don't know if it's
happening for real but I know it
happened in the past explicitly in this
virtual game that way is created so so
yes
yeah yeah
for those of new since you never mike is
like specific companies sending people
into a fire yeah and in fact there have
been some lawsuits of people against one
of these companies for sending them to
dangerous neighborhood like you you your
router sends you through a neighborhood
which is faster but you get attacked
along the way and so there are there are
a few lawsuits on record where people
have done that and it is a real problem
I mean it's funny because specifically
these quote dangerous neighborhoods
these companies learn very fast to route
around them and I don't know which
country it was in and war but yeah I
mean this is a the the fire the fire is
a problem the danger is a problem that
there's a few issues of that nature what
are the terms of service that's a user
what promise is actually made what's the
trade what's the plan so the question is
for the viewers online that's like what
are the terms of service I think nobody
read them because every click the SAS
yes yes yes so I think you consent to
everything including being killed
probably but frankly I don't know
because I never read them myself the
drivers is saving time yeah and I don't
know if that's ever stated in the in the
in in the Terms of Service or probably
not because I assume then you could sue
people for or sue the companies for
missing your plane because there might
have been a faster route but I assume
it's probably somewhere I frankly the
Terms of Service keep changing and I've
yet to find someone who ever read Terms
of Service for these apps I should
probably do it so just to give you a
sense of the magnitude of the problem
these are the places in the US where
where this has power in California where
this has popped up in the media so you
can imagine if there is a newspaper
article and sometimes it may actually
made the front page of The New York
Times on December 28th this year last
year it's crazy front page of the New
York Times I mean who would have thought
but essentially if you if you see if
this is hitting the news at this
frequency I mean it's really happening
everywhere and so I put them in a lot of
questions I think it's really good so I
probably won't have time to go through
the rest of the talk maybe the two
things I'd like to do is to show a movie
that that shows the
influence of information on routing and
why more information if not managed
properly is not necessarily helpful and
then I'll say a little bit about
learning and inference and then I will
probably stop for today so the movie
here is essentially a concatenation of
two movies this is a simulation in the
top movie you have it's a micro
simulation that means it simulates every
vehicle in the network and in the top
movie what it shows is what people do if
20 people 20 percent of the people have
the information 20 people 20 percent of
the people will do what selfish for
themselves and then here is you could
view it as what happened 10 years ago
when nobody had information so people
will just follow their usual patterns so
let me just play the movie and narrate
to the movie as it plays so as you zoom
in you'll see an accident happening so
an accident is a blockage so say a truck
spills over three lanes are blocked
it'll take Caltrans at one hour or two
hours to California Highway Patrol to
empty the freeway in that meantime the
app kicks in immediately gives you a
shortest path and now you have 20
percent of people who have the option to
keep to loop to leave the freeway
usually the app doesn't know that the
accident has been cleared it can measure
it later really doesn't know how long it
takes so by the time the accident is
cleared you still have a lot of people
leaving the freeway and a lot of the
routers have not updated and even if
they have this has now created a
bottleneck because a lot of people are
trying to leave the freeway so it's
interesting the first negative
externality is that by giving that
information you've now clogged the
freeway because a lot of people are
trying to leave that has actually
created additional congestion upstream
from the freeway but what's interesting
is that now all these people are on the
secondary road which is not which does
not have the capacity to process them
the intersections do not have the
capacity to process the external traffic
and these would were never the they were
never designed for it and the traffic
signals are not timed for it either now
you have all these extra vehicles that
create additional inefficiency in these
parallel networks and there's a
essentially a consequence of couplings
that create further clogging of the
freeway in the other
action and now you've even made the
traffic worse in the other direction so
this is purely empirical there's models
for it but what's interesting here is
that each of the steps I just narrated
the accident the bottleneck creation due
to the rerouting the bottleneck removal
the residual congestion and so on and so
forth all the things I just narrated
they're all things which are modeled
quite well there has been a ton of work
for over the last century to model them
in the independence and fixing them in
Independence that something people know
to do but what this information is us
created is essentially a concatenation
of them which makes it nearly impossible
for afraid to be controlled and so this
is just illustrative of what information
is created and maybe to finish the talk
on a slightly more vertical note what
I'd like to do is to give a sense of
what happens when essentially this loop
that I talked about starts to operate at
large scale and the system starts to
learn how to react to these selfish
behavior so I'm gonna just show this
curve so this is a result of a model the
modeling traffic has an article burg
game in which you have selfish users who
do the best thing for themself and you
have other users who just do things that
would do otherwise and what you see is
that if you plot the evolution of travel
time as a function of the proportion of
people using the app ten years ago when
nobody was using the app zero percent
you had a pretty low travel time on the
arterial roads here like and this little
stretch the green roads and you had
pretty high travel time on the freeway
and the more people are diverted
essentially the lower the freeway travel
time gets that's normal because people
leave the freeway so technically it kind
of helps but of course the first words
get congested so it gets much higher
travel time then people start to use the
second road and it also gets congested
at at some point the travel time is
equalized and for anybody who has
studied economics then you'll recognize
that's a convergence to a Nash
equilibrium and that's why all the
claims that the elected officials made
about you know if you give people
selfish information it makes traffic
better
well no John Nash got a Nobel Prize for
being the same
that half a century ago and so what
information is done is it has enabled
people to play that gigantic nash game
in which they are able to compete for
sim commodity and do it
selfishly and so today there's the
situation in which we are is essentially
a multi player situation in which
anybody can use any app they want and
any app will route people selfishly
based on their belief of what's best for
their customers and maybe they will
split the flows maybe they won't we
don't really know what's below the hood
and that system essentially operates as
a system of black boxes that are not
coordinated and obviously are all
competing against each other so it's
kind of a bunch of closed feedback loops
on everybody using their phone what's
interesting is that system evolves over
time and so that system as more data
comes in the the companies that brought
you they learn over time how to write
you better if you've been using Google
or ways or Apple for the last five years
you've noticed the app has changed the
routes they give you have change that
because the algorithm is learning over
time so that is something that can be
modeled as a repeated game so this is
the game is essentially an instantiation
of that system action at the beginning
and the learning is month after month
the app learns how to route their
contentions better and so there is a
very nice repeated game formulation of
it and the one question that we should
all collectively ask ourself is if every
day the apps are splitting flows
according to what they think is better
for people and at the end of the day
they discover how well they did because
they can measure everybody what learning
algorithm should they use so that
overall things improve so you can view
the learning algorithm as an evolution
of what the split the next they should
be as a function of what he learned from
the outcome of the game the previous day
and so that the type of work we do now
is trying to study these learning
algorithms to say are there anything we
could say about them and so far the
depressing conclusion we have is that
most of the models we find all end up
inevitably converging to Nash solutions
which means even if people are
continuing to play and the system is
evolving because the system
never really at equilibrium when it
converges it still converges to Nash
equilibria and so just skipping to the
three main results here so I'm just
gonna go I'm gonna skip all the
equations but just show the three
results here is that depending on the
assumption you make about the way the
apps learn if you make almost no if you
make almost no assumption on the way
they learn you just assume it's a no
regret learning strategy then you can't
even show that the system converts so
it's essentially saying that if the
algorithms put together by the companies
to learn over time how people who are
themselves don't have specific
assumptions then you don't even know
that the system is stable and there have
been known gridlocks created in many
cities by these apps and you could view
this as an early instantiation of this
lack of stability of the system if you
make further more restrictive
assumptions on the way the app learned
and you can prove that you have
essentially a form of convergence it's
almost your convergence of these
distributions which is encouraging and
in even more restrictive assumptions
where you assume that the lab the apps
learn in the form of the word ascent
then you can prove convergence rates of
the way the distributions evolve over
time but all these convergence in the
best case still converts to a Nash
equilibrium which is not good because
for anybody who has study economics then
you would know that you know naturally
in most of the system there's a price of
Anarchy and it's nonzero which means
essentially yes you converge to a Nash
equilibrium is better than instability
but still you're they're not at system
optimum where you would like to be and
so at the core of this lying in this
these situations that these companies
are only looking at current state of the
roads when you are showing that zoom in
and you walked us through that bad
situation it looked like a not even very
sophisticated model would be able to
make
actions of the dynamics into the near
future do you think that these Nash
equilibrium results will hold if the
companies do make more of a predictive
or use more this is a very deep question
yeah so the question for the viewers are
if I try to summarize the long question
is can we say anything about the impact
of the quality of the forecast of this
company on what it would converge to
even these companies we're doing
forecasting bleed so it's a very good
question because if you think about all
the just list five or six different ways
they do it so ten years ago essentially
the way they would compute travel time
is posted speed limit okay so when there
was no information you'd pick the speed
limit and that's that's the yeah that's
your forecast model then a little bit
later they move to historical forecasts
okay that was a bit better then about
ten years ago they moved to nowcast
which is essentially you measuring what
you have now and you assume it doesn't
change and that's your forecast then
they move to statistical forecast which
i think is still where most of the
state-of-the-art is now so you measure
now cast you know that when now cast is
this then most likely forecast is that
and that's your forecast and then the
real way to do is to really do a flow
prediction which is also contingent on
doing the man doing a flow prediction is
called the dynamic traffic assignment
that's essentially having a forecast
model that is initialized with the
nowcast and may be fed with some
statistical forecast for demand I could
bet you that no company today is doing
that because it's super hard and it's
really my question is not I believe
they're not doing that yet the real
question is if they did do that would
that make things better or worse and
this is very interesting because so I
don't know and this needs to be studied
because essentially now when you you
essentially have a controller that is
controlling your plant with a
version of the future so it's like doing
MPC with a version of the future that
can only be as good as your future so I
assume that with some guarantees on that
future maybe you can prove that it's
better maybe but I but I don't know and
so that's an open problem that's a
problem we're working on that's a
problem to which I don't know the
solution and that's a very important
problem because everybody's gonna
forecast the future but they only have
partial information because Google does
not know what the apple drivers will do
it vice-versa so even then there is a
game in predicting the future so you can
see why this problem is extremely
complex and and this is open I mean if
anybody has any idea on how to solve
this I would love to talk because I
think that's one of the holy grail of of
cracking this problem and you can also
imagine why this is hard to convey in in
the newspaper I mean obviously so when
people assume that if you I mean the the
notion that the quality of your forecast
and the non-cooperative nature of your
forecast with partial information is
going to affect the outcome it's it's
complicated so summary of the of the
talk at the core of this problem is
selfishness which is you know we all
want to get to our destination faster
that creates this dynamics loop I have
created here that is part of this bigger
system which essentially is the way it
runs and that bigger system itself gets
abstracted by the app providers that
learn over time how things work and the
reason why that learning is important is
that part is done I mean 100% of the
population statistically has a
smartphone if you average the fact that
people have more than one connected
object but what's changing constantly is
demographic growth will reach 50 million
people in California by 2050 I believe
and then obviously locally like when I
was a student at Stanford there was a
small start-up called Google and we just
found in the newspaper that if they
piled up all the buildings there was in
the news yesterday it would be a tower
which is eight hundred and fifty four
meters high I think with a hundred and
twenty floors and so now there's
probably 40,000 people on the campus and
that has completely changed the dynamics
of traffic there's a factory of Tesla
which grew
overnight with 5,000 people in the next
three years there will be 18,000 units
open in Treasure Island in the middle of
Bay Bridge you can imagine what it will
do to traffic so the point is and this
is when the agent kicks in right because
the agent over time learns every month
there's X thousand more people and
that's way to learn so these these
problems are really important because
this is the way the system learns over
time and we have to understand how it
learns if we want to manage it better so
I'm gonna stop here because I think
we're at the end of the of the talk but
I'd be very happy to answer any question
and yeah no I think they can a Simon's
Institute for inviting me here today and
Peter for organizing the session Thank
You Josh so satellite imagery I guess
now we're able to get to limit Rihanna
unit time skills on some parts of the
world is are you using that does that
help
obviously there's clouds that's an issue
but is there some extra ground truth you
get from that one day's yeah so I spoke
with Dale are their children often home
for some out in Germany because they
were able to reprogram the satellite to
orbit over California but ten years ago
lower low orbit I think and I'm not an
expert in telemetry they were showing
ten years ago then they could capture
70% of the moving vehicles from the
orbit imagery there's an issue of
real-time and everything but I believe
that I believe that this could provide
probably the best data there is for
ground truthing assuming you have good
visibility so it would be it would be
really interesting I think this is
probably the only way to get global
ground truth because as soon as you
start to probe people GPS then you
always have the issue of who's
transmitting and who is not transmitting
I think if we get access to that kind of
data I think it'd be really great I
heard and you probably know a lot more
than I do but I heard some large
corporation acquired a satellite company
some time ago where they could see their
competitors trucks shipping so if that
can be done I assume we can do a lot
more good things
if you have if you had a system that was
able to keep the Nash equilibrium
presumably one company that give advice
to all drivers it seems almost
inevitable that you would have two
drivers and make exactly the same
circumstances who would have to be given
different recommendations yes and one
might turn out to be better than the
other
yes which raises a whole fairness issue
absolutely okay so the question for the
viewers is if you had a company that had
a hundred percent of the access to
everybody's driving and two people were
going to the exact same location from
the exact same location in practice they
would be potentially given different
recommendations one be better than
another and then their whole issue of
fairness so and the thing is Balaji
Prabhakar is very involved in this and I
think what you will probably show or
have shown in throughout this workshop
is that people will not give half an
hour of their life for a free cappuccino
because it's not worth it given your
consulting rate and so then the question
of fairness becomes who gets the
information and and who gets the good
information and there have been a few
companies over the last couple of months
which have started to make very timid
statements that some people might get
better recommendations than others and
that's for the greater good of society
but obviously it's a very bad value
proposition so I don't think they can
push it the truth is the only way to
make sure that people get better or
worse or combination and each other
which is the only way you can
systematically optimize because if you
want to reach system up to them someone
has got to pay the penalty for the
greater good and that in terms if you
measure in terms of trial time so you
have to compensate the fact that you
have incurred that penalty by something
else free goodies are not gonna work
but access restriction is likely to be
the thing that is gonna work and so for
example if you look at the one on one
corridor today this corridor is
completely asphyxiated by the growth of
economic activity because of Facebook
Google and all the other big companies
the only way they can save travel time
reliability is by making either access
restriction a bus lane or tolling which
is problematic because
the gas tax and so I think what you see
happening around the world is true in
Singapore is that tolling more access
restriction is probably the only way to
make sure that now someone is going to
take the penalty because some people
don't want to pay at all and if you make
the toll high enough certainly they will
not pay that all or if they cannot get
ten people in a vehicle because it's a
smaller vehicle they won't be able to
access the lane and so now that's how
you offset the penalty and travel time
with money it's very hard to do with a
carrot because carrots are hard to make
work but it's hard it's easier to do
with sticks but sticks have issues
because now the going back to your first
problem about fairness well if you have
a tax on the specific oil or who's going
to be affected by it and that's a whole
other dimension of the problem which
policymakers have been struggling with
for a while and that is not easy to
solve with regard to individual drivers
motivation travel time has been the sole
one here could could you could you
smooth out it could you affect affect
that equilibrium by offering another
currency
perhaps risk so this is very interesting
there's a very to the individual to make
those trades and hope that the
absolutely very interesting question if
you go to the airport in general you
don't want the expected shortest time
because because that's not expected
value doesn't do anything for you to
miss your flight
you want the path that maximizes your
probability of on arrival time on-time
arrival that's called sotas stochastic
on-time arrival there's a very amazing
group at Cornell led by Samhita Samara
Naoki who is working on that problem a
former graduate of Berkeley and instead
of minimizing your expected value Humana
Meyer you met you you maximize your
probability of arrival on time by the
way this is super hard to convey to
people on the on an app so even though
everybody probably in these companies
realize that's the right thing to do I
don't think any company will be able to
even pull a product where they can
explain to someone that concept it's
very very hard to convey simply
but the interesting policy question that
you raise is what people really care
about in many cases is reliability like
if you're going to Google from San
Francisco you want to be able to not
miss you want to be you don't wanna miss
your meeting half of the time because
travel is unreliable and what's very
interesting is that who benefits from a
carpool that is becoming a higher
occupancy carpool lane like the fact
that if suddenly the carpooling become a
bus lane on the 101 now travel time
becomes reliable if you're driving the
bus because because we're not saturated
the number of buses on that Lane so I
think there's two growth before it
saturates and today if you look at who
is lobbying for this and if you think of
who is even in favor of this you'll find
that uber and lyft are both of both made
statements in favor of how to keep and
sea lanes because if I'm a company like
a TNC what I would like to sell is
travel time reliability and the way to
sell it is to push occupancy which
restricts access and pass the cost to
customers the more customers in the
vehicle the more the cost gets absorbed
by the number of customers so it's
interesting because I think well the way
we're gonna see these tnc work in the
future is they will push for more
legislation that would advocate for
higher occupancy vehicle lanes which is
a way to push travel time reliability as
uber I would like to be able to provide
an uber service from San Francisco to
the airport of this guaranteed 13
minutes if it's guaranteed 13 minutes
because there's always five people in
the pool and the pool gets to access a
special Lane then as a company I have an
amazing product and so I think we're
gonna see this happening over the rest
over the next couple of years in many
cities like essentially these companies
are going to start advocating and
advocating because they provide a good
and interesting product for people that
doesn't exist there I mean when I go to
the airport in the morning it's you know
yeah you only have a little bit of an
adrenaline rush if there's an accident
you don't want that offer to not count
the driver as part of the HOV
requirement well that's another issue
but I think as long as you get a HOV 4
then it becomes moot but you're right I
mean because today the driver
technically is a passenger so that's an
poll it needs to be fixed yeah so I
think you already answered that son I'm
just repeating but why do the companies
not themselves enter into a treaty
obligation more efficiently I think you
already answered it because it has
something with having to differentiate
customers I think there is probably
several levels of answer to that
question first it's even striking that
they don't do it internally like there
are probably countries where there's
only a single running app that people
massively use and even that company
would not do it
because I think the first level of
answer is that it's gonna be super hard
to convey to the public going back to
your question that someone is incurring
a penalty because the only way to have a
treaty is that some people have to pay
the price that you have to offset if so
I think that's a first level of answer
then the second level of answer is that
I mean it is the prisoner's dilemma or
the notion of a national anybody who
deviates from the Nash equilibrium is
that worse off so I mean how do you make
sure that these two companies who are
main competitors you know and how you
enforce it and can you subpoena and so
there's there's probably several several
layers or reasons that need to be
overcome why that has not been done
they're sequential but you've got to
start internal yeah they're sequential
you're right
I draw a ruling in the next role
[Applause]
I